- What are the top three
keys to being happy?
(upbeat sunny music)
- My name is H-A-N-K, and that spells Hank
and I am 4 and a half.
- I'm looking for tips
on how to be more happy.
Do you have any advice?
- If I do something like cool
it makes me feel like happy.
- I think being with people you love
will trigger happiness so much
because you're always
just chillin', you know?
You chillin'?
- Yeah!
- When I hang out with my family.
When cats appear.
- Like out of the darkness?
When they just appear?
- I wouldn't say like that, but--
- Oh, okay. (laughing)
- What can I do to be happier?
- What stuff you love to do?
- I love dancing, I love going out to eat,
I love finessing billionaires.
- Everyday.
- Okay.
- Even if you're here, for two minutes
you go outside and you say,
"Guys, I need my two minutes."
Everyday, and you're gonna go
and you're gonna turn your favorite jam on
and you're gonna dance.
- I'm gonna dance?
- You're doing dance.
- I'm gonna dance.
(techno music)
- Get 'em!
- Hey, okay, okay.
- I can't really help you
with finessing billionaires,
I wish I could.
- You know what?
I'm still working on that.
- You'll get there, you'll there.
- I'll get there.
- What does happiness mean?
- It means feeling, having a good day
and feeling good about yourself.
- Yeah, that's a good answer.
- I just feel like I could
just slide over a rainbow.
- What are your top
three keys to happiness?
- Cats, chocolate and candy.
- Oh my gosh.
- And my friends.
And my family.
- I like where your friends
and family come on that list.
(laughing)
- What's something you do when you want
to make yourself happy?
That's a good thing not to do.
- Is it okay to do bad
things if it makes you happy?
- Depends what kind of bad things, okay?
If you're robbing people's houses
and that's what makes you
happy, you need to stop.
- Do you ever have a sad day?
- Well.
Not really, I usually have happy days.
- That must be so nice.
- Well if you just join the beautiful day
you'll have a good time.
- Do you have any tips for
making my mornings happier
so that I get out of bed?
- If you have an alarm
clock, don't make it
like that annoying ringing,
make it a pleasant sound
that makes you really want to get up.
If you love dancing, put dance music
so it makes you feel
energized and you just dance.
- Oh my gosh.
- Your heart out.
- Like a trap music alarm clock?
- Yeah.
- That sounds amazing.
- Have you ever heard of depression?
- Yeah, it's a very deep sadness.
It's when something's happened
that you can't recover from
and you get in this
place where it's so hard
to come back up.
I've dealt with depression, too.
There have been times where
I went to school everyday
and just got mauled and bullied
and it sucked so bad but
I found the people I love
and the things I love to support me.
You got through it and I got through it
so tell all the people
who are watching this.
- You can get through it.
- My sister hasn't been
talking to me lately.
How do I get her to talk
to me? What can I do?
- Oh so if I say it louder,
that'll get through to her?
- Yeah.
- So sometimes, do you
know what Instagram is?
- No.
- Okay, I go on my phone
and I can look at pictures
of what all my friends are doing.
So they're on like vacation,
doing these amazing things
with their career and
they seem really happy
and then sometimes that makes me sad
like I should be doing more.
Do you know any way that
I could not feel that way?
- Maybe if you just not look at them?
(triumphant music)
- Genius.
You know what, I'm going to
delete my Instagram right now.
I'm just kidding, I can't do that.
- God.
- What makes you happy?
- I would say my family
and then my friends.
And I really, really
like going to the beach.
- Me, too, definitely.
- That's a happy place,
let's be honest.
This is good.
- Joyce, what makes you happy?
- I like to collect like
old books so I like to go
to the library sometimes.
- Awesome.
- And I like to read really
old dusty romance books
on weekends because of many reasons
but that's what makes me happy.
- That's awesome.
- What would you do if there
was something you could do
to make every person in the world happy?
What do you think that would be?
Yeah, loving everybody?
- Yes.
- That's a good answer.
- What do you like to
do with your friends?
- I like to usually play around with them.
- Like play like dress up?
- Well we don't really
usually play dress up.
- Hmm.
- It's been a long time.
- Same.
- Even if you're feeling
really, really sad, just smile.
Work on your smiling and that will always
make you feel better even
if you're the saddest
of saddest of sads.
- I like that.
- Just smile.
- Can you give me smile?
(triangle chiming)
- If you just don't
think about the badness,
you'll just have goodness.
- That's really insightful.
- So any last advice for me, Mr. Toby?
- You are definitely a joyful person.
Your parents named you Joyce for a reason.
- Oh good.
- So you should live
like your name, you should
be Joyce the joyful.
- Thank you so much, Toby.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.